this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be breaking down
the iconic weaponry
of hitman 3. so as a ballpark it's a
short weapon but it's
not nearly short enough to fit in that
briefcase it just kind of magics its way
out of that briefcase i'm clearly not
going for maximum realism here
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics you want to see jonathan break
down let us know in the comments below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
exactly like this and if you want to
help out the royal armies museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
you can check out the links in the
description of this video right
over to jonathan goodluck 47.
okay first up we've got the uh thinly
disguised kruger meyer 2 2
which does contain the name of the real
gun ruger
which is the name of bill ruger who
founded the ruger company pretty good
representation of the ruger mark 2 mark
iii
it's actually marked mark 3 visibly in
the game uh it is sort of
a fantasy version it doesn't quite match
in in detail
but if i grab an example you'll see how
close it really is but this
is actually a real vintage piece this is
the mark one
i think the only thing that really
sticks out for me for being nitpicky
is the trigger guard which is very picky
of me
but um the rugers all have this
traditional rounded printed guard just
sort of made a comeback these days
the game model has the squared off
trigger guard which was invented
in the 80s for a two-handed grip where
the left finger wraps around the trigger
guard
really quite a quiet pistol probably
about as quiet as it gets with a
suppressor of this
volume it's not very wide it's very long
and
2-2 especially if you uh load subsonic
tutu
would actually be maybe not a million
miles away from how it's depicted in
this clip the sound is a little bit sort
of
uh the pitch is a bit movie tv maybe but
um
it's definitely not just the pew pew
sound they've done a little little
better with this i think
that stings
we've got we've reached the iconic
hitman silver baller
pistol 45 acp and i'm smiling
because the biker that just got shot
was shot in the knee and remarked
that stinks which i don't think has ever
happened i think any bullet to the knee
is probably
problematic at best and a four to five
is a big old heavy slug i'm clearly not
going for maximum realism here
the pistol has obviously been in the
series since
i think the beginning silver baller as
i'm sure people already know
comes from hardballer which is the model
name
of the gun it's based on so the amt
hardballer
so here it is disappointingly i know it
doesn't have a suppressor in it
and that's really a function of it being
a
target pistol slash competition
versatile uh not much calling either of
those rolls
for a threaded barrel which is what you
need to fit a suppressor
so that classic shiny sound suppressor
on the end
doesn't happen in real life unless you
make it happen in real life
so as well as the um the hardballer
silver ball of being a bit of
a bit of an old gun of course the 1911
um
it's in the name it's well over 100
years old now so is this really
something that uh
an international super assassin would be
using it's fiction
of course but there are better options
including
the roruga tutu that we've already seen
a lot of the kills in the hitman games
are done at close range
and 2-2 suppresses so well that you
genuinely might get away without being
detected
a 45 full full-size pistol
with a typical suppressor on it that
that sound although it sounds quite
authentic to me what we're not getting
is the real world volume of that
indoors the pop of a 45
going off with a suppressor on it is
still loud as loud as a balloon going
off and if you've ever jumped at a
balloon getting popped
then you know that this is not super
quiet and
in the in the some of the really quiet
settings that we get in these games
people are going to hear you so not that
suitable from a practical standpoint
kind of really old hat in terms of the
gun design and
well actually the the caliber the the
cartridge
is about the only thing that does fit
because if you want to
incapacitate or kill some something very
quickly at close range
a big heavy bullet like 45 is yeah it's
an option the problem is it's still got
a
fair old powder charge in the case so
it's going to still make it
quite a noise
we've got a quite an interesting
slightly sci-fi looking
pistol up next more interestingly maybe
is the improvised sound suppressor which
is a real trend now in games
come over from the real world where it's
possible in theory to attach
something like an oil filter to a pistol
and that's because
the gentleman who founded gemtech
suppressors once told me
you can get the same sound suppression
as
as their pistols are present with a
potato
stuck on the end of a gumball problem of
course is that you only get that sound
suppression for one shot but that's
that's why these improvised suppressors
would actually work where it falls down
is the attachment
you need to be able to fit it to the gun
you need a standardized thread
on the end of the barrel and some sort
of adapter
to fit on this paint spray can you'd
have to spray all of the contents out
you'd have to follow it out you'd need
to diy this thing onto your gun you
can't just
stick it on the end like that but if
once you've got it on there there's
enough volume in the paint canvas
work i don't know how well and i don't
think it'd be very robust
in the spectrum of sound suppressors
it's one up from a potato
welcome
there is the walther or walter
sorry germany wa 2000 ballpark sniper
rifle or something very close to it
see it behind me pretty close but the
general shape the thumb hole
pistol grip and the mixture of wood and
finished metal
is general shape they're all pretty much
there i think this probably was
introduced into the franchise as a
result of the
bond movie the living daylights which
this gun
was hired out for you can see when um
when agent 47 is moving around the
environment that the short
the relatively short length of a
ballpark with a long barrel in a short
stop
is a real it would be a realistic
advantage so as a ballpark it's a short
weapon
but it's not nearly short enough to fit
in that briefcase as agent 47 is taking
it out of the briefcase
it just kind of magics its way out of
that very short
briefcase it's not a takedown design and
in the game it's not either so he's not
taking the barrel out and fitting it to
the stock
which is what you'd have to do to fit
any kind of sniper rifle
into anything smaller than a very large
secret we're stretching reality there
but you know
we have a strong tradition of video
games of pulling guns out of miniature
black holes
the other thing about this weapon in the
game is the
cavalier nature in which agent 47 treats
the thing
throwing weapons is never a good idea
with a precision rifle like this
any any knock to the scope could
absolutely destroy your ability to
accurately shoot the weapon
dropping it even would be a bad idea
never mind hurling it in its
briefcase at somebody as fun as that is
and then at one point we see we see it
thrown off a rooftop
in its case i don't know maybe whatever
black hole the gun hides in when it's in
the case protects it from impacts as
well i don't know
but it's not not to be recommended
throwing precision-engineered
pieces of machinery from rooftops is not
conducive to their
good function you almost feel like a god
looking down on your creation but back
to business
it's interesting we haven't come across
each other before mister
kyle ingram finally gets what he
deserves
yeah that's a weird gun that's basically
entirely fictional so i i had to cheat
and look at um
the excellent imf db here but um the the
hyzer defense double tap which is
actually a tip-up barrel deringer just
like an old west derringer but modern
version of it
stylistically is very similar to this
thing this thing
is bizarre because not only does it not
have a magazine in the pistol grip
it doesn't have it can't be loaded at
all why would you have a pistol you
can't reload
no i do it sort of makes thematic sense
in terms of it being an assassination
weapon you get five
rounds and that's that's your lot it's
caseless we know that from the
description and the fact that no cases
come out and it fires
presumably because leaving cartridge
cases behind could lead to being
detected
but i don't think that's ever been a
problem for agent 47 also in terms of
its
visual design it it visibly has
a slide assembly on it so it's it's got
all of the
all of the parts necessary to reload
each shot
all that's missing is the magazine why
doesn't it why didn't they take
a step forward and design a magazine for
it gameplay reasons
that's the only the only logical reason
i can think of for a gun that you can't
reload
is to encourage you to use this
weapon in the game
sniper rifles of course are somewhat
prominent in the gameplay
of the hitman games and this is a
like if you squint really hard it's um a
dragon of
svd but yeah it's it's substantially
different than the real
svd rifle what really strikes me about
this is the um
insane physics going on so we see uh
every time a bullet hits a character
they are
flying backward in fact a couple of
times like they were they flipped
like 180 and face planted
onto the deck which looks cool but of
course it's completely impossible
because i'm not sure what in in-game
caliber this is but the
the 762 by 54 russian cartridge
does not have the the power to do that
and then schoolboy physics would tell
you that if you could knock somebody
a yard backward you would be displaced
by that amount by pulling the trigger
thanks for watching everyone i'm looking
forward to playing this game at some
point myself
um not so much from the from the
accuracy standpoint but
the gameplay really does look superb
museums are struggling a bit at the
moment so
um if if you feel you you would like to
we do have a link in the description to
donate
or even to become a member of the royal
armouries
and that would be great but just
watching is great
too
[Music]
you